yeah this all happened uh about 9 50
last night 10 p.m Harry and Megan have
been at this woman of vision event at
which she was lauded for her
contribution to Human Rights and gender
equality a red carpet event you know
lots of media there a happy occasion
they were there in the presence of
Megan's mother that was it the the Zeke
felt Ballroom just around the corner
from from Trump Tower and Midtown
Manhattan a very busy place they then
left the building and that's when things
happened and there is I might say two
sides to the story emerging as to to
what unfolded after they left that
building over the next couple of hours
we have that statement from Harry and
Megan's spokesperson talking about a
near catastrophic event talking about
Paparazzi in Pursuit that endangered
Harry Megan and her mother people inside
their vehicle and everybody else my
understanding is that that related to
something like half a dozen blacked out
Paparazzi Vehicles which uh were
committing a number of traffic offenses
going the wrong way on a one-way Street
driving on the pavement taking pictures
on the Move using the mobile phone on
the move and the world from Harry and
Megan's people is that that put
everybody in danger now in the last few
minutes we've had guidance reportable
guidance from two senior law enforcement
officials in New York that's come to us
from our sister organization NBC here in
the United States and I'll read you some
of what they have to say because it is
not square with the version First put
out by Harry and Megan it does flesh out
detail but their conclusion is different
they speak about how they left the Zeke
felt Ballroom Harry and Megan had
private security with them they wanted
to go back to where they were staying on
the Upper East Side you know Harry and
Megan had made arrangements to stay at
the private residence of a friend a lot
of Paparazzi were at the Ziegfeld
according to these officials members of
the press didn't know where Harry and
Megan were staying so the photographers
wanted to follow them Harry and Megan
didn't want Paparazzi to know where they
were going
so they were driven across 57th Street
in Manhattan up and down the Franklin D
Roosevelt Drive and other streets for
about an hour and 15 minutes
one NYPD vehicle New York police
department vehicle was escorting theirs
they drove to the 19th Precinct that's a
police station they stayed there around
15 minutes police helped get the pair
off the block they got into a different
car and they got to the residence
without being followed
the officials are describing it as a bit
of a chaotic scene to use their words
they say that they do not believe that
it was courts near catastrophic now in
terms of the other vehicle there are
pictures uh not yet published they may
be published in due course of Harry and
Megan in a yellow New York Taxi
now one image in particular is striking
Jane if anybody remembers the the image
through the windscreen of Princess Diana
in the taxi that crashed causing her
death hungry Paul the driver looking
down the battle of the lens through his
glasses smiling in the passenger seat
the security guard travel reached Jones
busying himself and in the back seat you
catch a glimpse of Diana well there is
at least one image uh which is
strikingly similar driver security guard
and the back seat you can see Megan and
that's the parallel that causes so much
concern isn't it for Harry and Megan
because he is a man who blames the
paparazzi who blames the media blames
their intrusion for causing the death of
his mother I was there 1997 oh sign bar
model a 12 year old Harry Ashen faced
looking at floral tributes to his mother
from that day he has blamed the media
and Its Behavior for the death of his
nearest and dearest and this clearly
resonates with him so many years on but
as I say there is a disagreement in
terms of the versions of events and just
how dangerous this Paparazzi Pursuit
laws